it appears that blizzards first-ever FPS
overwatch is already a success with the
developer claiming it's already seen
more than 7 million players since launch
I'm Dave and welcome to your heroes
never die news update Matt Baker
combines totals on pc xbox one and ps4
across all three platforms 119 million
hours of the game have been played since
launch on May twenty-fourth citing
unspecified internal data and reports
from distribution partners the company
proclaims overwatch is one of the most
successful global game launches of all
time although it's unclear exactly what
metrics are used to determine this
whatever the case overwatch is quickly
approaching the player total it racked
up during mais open beta over nine point
seven million people try that beta which
essentially amounted to a free demo
lizard shared a few other numbers today
players have switched characters 326
million times and delivered 11 million
payload since launch unfortunately it
didn't have any further data to offer
regarding players accomplishments or
preferences as it did following the beta
overwatch will add a competitive play
mode later this month and more content
is slated for release sometime this
summer in the meantime Blizzard isn't
shying away from banning cheaters and is
hoping to improve its player the game
sequence that follows every match so
have you been playing blizzards latest
game who's your favorite hero let us
know in the comments section below or
find me on Twitter at irregular Dave and
for your overwatch news stay tuned to
gamespot
you